>>THIS MORNING, A JUDGE WILL
HEAR ARGUMENTS IN TWITTER'S
REQUEST TO SPEED ITS LAWSUIT
AGAINST ELON MUSK.
>> MUSK IS TRYING TO BACK OUT OF
BUYING THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT,
SAYING THEY'RE HOLDING THE THE
NUMBER OF HUMAN USERS ON THE
PLATFORM VERSUS HOW MANY ARE
BOTS.
BUT TWITTER IS SUING TO FORCE
MUSK TO COMPLETE THE $44 BILLION
DEAL.
JOINING US NOW IS JOURNALIST AND
CONTRIBUTOR TO WIRE.COM, CHRIS
STOKER WALKER.
IT IS A COMPELLING READ, THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING,
CHRIS.
>> ONE THING I JUST THINK WE
SHOULD FORGET IN ALL OF THIS IS
THIS IS AN ARGUMENT AGAINST WHO
IS REAL AND WHO IS NOT, THE
USERS.
IN THE MERGER AGREEMENT THAT
MUSK SIGNED ON
AND THE SAME FOR TWITTER, THERE
IS NO MENTION OF WHO IS REAL AND
WHO IS NOT.
THIS IS YET THE GROUND ON WHICH
HE IS TRYING TO PULL OUT.
HOW PRECARIOUS LEGALLY DOES THAT
MAKE MUSK'S ARGUMENT HERE?
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY
SIGNATURE.
I THINK IT'S NOTABLE, BECAUSE
ANY LAWYER WORTH HIS OR HER SALT
WILL PROBABLY BE POINTING TO
THAT AND SAYING ELON MUSK
PROBABLY WANTED TO TAKE OVER
TWITTER WAY BACK IN APRIL
BECAUSE HE THINKS TWITTER HAS
TOO MUCH OF A PROBLEM.
NOW, SUDDENLY, WE GET TO JULY,
AND FAST FORWARD TO THIS POINT
AND HE IS TRYING TO BACK OUT
BECAUSE, AGAIN, HE THINKS
TWITTER HAS TOO MUCH OF A BOT
PROBLEM.
FILING TO THE S.E.C. SAYING 5%
OR FEW ARE ITS ACCOUNT AND
TWITTER HAS HELD TO THAT AND
MUSK DISAGREES.
BUT SOME OF THE METHODOLOGY HE
IS SUGGESTING TO TRY WHAT IS AND
ISN'T IS A SHAKY TO THE
SCIENTISTS I TALK TO.
BUT YEAH.
I THINK ULTIMATELY THE WHOLE --
HERE IS A BIT OF A FAST.
>> THE CHANCE FOR DUE DILIGENCE
BEFORE SIGNING THAT DEAL.
THE OTHER THING THAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE IS THAT SINCE HE
SIGNED THIS DEAL, TWITTER'S
STOCK MARKET VALUE HAS DROPPED
ALONG WITH THE REST OF THE STOCK
MARKET AS HAS TESLA'S STOCK
VALUE.
BY THE WAY, HE WAS GOING TO
BORROW A LOT OF MONEY FROM TESLA
TO MAKE THIS PURCHASE HERE.
WHY SHOULD NOT JUST THE PEOPLE
AT HOME BUT WHY SHOULD THE COURT
BELIEVE HIS DESIRE TO PULL OUT
IS NOT TIED TO THE DROPPING
GRAPHS YOU SEE ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT NOW BUT RATHER TO THE BOT
ISSUE AS HE CLAIMS?
>> TRUTHFULLY, I THINK THERE IS
ANY JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT.
WE ARE SEEING ELON MUSK'S BEING
CALLED HERE.
HE OFFERED TO BUY TWITTER OVER
38% OF WHAT IT WAS TRADING AT
THE AT THE BEGINNING OF APRIL
AND WE HAVE SEEN SINCE THEN THE
PRICE IS CRATERING.
NOW IT SEEMS DOUBTFUL THAT VALUE
WILL EVER BE REQUIRED.
IF WE DON'T LOOK BACK AT THE
LAST THREE MONTHS, WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED, YOU KNOW?
ELON MUSK KIND OF DRAGGED
TWITTER'S NAME THROUGH THE MUD
AND, LIKEWISE, TWITTER FALL BACK
AND SAID ELON MUSK ISN'T A FIT
PERSON.
I THINK WE ARE IN THIS TWILIGHT
ZONE.
THAT DOESN'T REAL ESLY THINK HEN
RUN THE COMPANY.
>> LET'S TAKE THE BILLIONAIRES
OUT OF THE EQUATION.
WHAT MATTERS TO MOST OF THE
FOLKS HERE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE.
SORT OF AVERAGE FOLKS.
AND YOU'VE BEEN TALKING TO
EMPLOYEES AT TWITTER.
YOU TALK HOW THEY SORT OF FEEL
LE
LEADER-LESS.
WHAT HAS THIS DONE FOR THEIR
MORALE?
>> IT'S ON THE FLOOR.
TWITTER HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ENTIRELY ON PREPARING ITSELF FOR
THIS PURCHASE AND FOR THIS
PURCHASE TO GO THROUGH.
SO THERE HAS BEEN A FREEZE ON
HIRING.
I SPOKE TO SOMEONE WHO WAS
OFFERED A JOB FROM TWITTER THIS
YEAR EARLIER AND HAD THE JOB
OFFER RESCINDED BECAUSE OF THE
DEAL.
I TALKED TO CURRENT EMPLOYEES
WHO SAY THINGS BASICALLY AREN'T
GETTING DOWN.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO LEAVE
BECAUSE OF UNHAPPINESS AND
SIMPLY THEIR CONTRACTS RUN OUT
AND ULTIMATELY THINGS START TO
FALL BY THE WAYSIDE.
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
HERE.
I'M GOING TO BE REPORTING ON A
STORY LATER TODAY WHERE THERE IS
A MORE SIGNIFICANT ISSUE BEYOND
MUSK IN TERMS OF MORALE AND PAY
AT TWITTER.
>> YEAH.
AND HAS IT POISONED TWITTER FOR
OTHER POTENTIAL SUITORS IN THE
BROADER MARKET.
CHRIS STOKEL-WALKER, THANK YOU